really awesome consumer experiences for
the masses
>> start high-end. Yes.
>> Like air travel.
>> Yes.
>> Used to be very high-end and now it's
awesome that so many people in the world
can afford to fly on a plane. Like
everyone should have the same quality
healthcare that a head of state has.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And I think that's going to happen.
That's doable.
>> This is Dalton plus Michael. Today we're
going to talk about AI and consumer
startups. Y we're familiar with
consumer. We did a little bit of that.
>> We were consumer founders back in the
day. We were when we had no gray hair.
To break this down, we were having this
conversation that was really
interesting. I think that the starting
point was when you said back in the day,
just putting something online made
something 10x better. And so, you know,
often times when we think about kind of
new products, it's kind of taking
something that's like really, really
high-end that the rich people get and
giving it to everyone. That's the
Clayton Christensen kind of disruption.
And you made this point that for so many
things, just putting this experience
online or on the phone made it
delivering a premium experience to um
everyone. Flush that a little bit more.
>> Yeah. when you're competing with
nothing, if the alternative is
>> paper
>> is [laughter]
non-existent.
Um, it is much easier to blow people
away with the experience. And so for me
as a consumer, the first time I used
Napster,
>> yeah,
>> I was like, okay, so this is all the
music and I [laughter] can and and it's
free and like every C I don't have to
buy CDs and the alternative was like CDs
were expensive.
>> Yeah. I can't stress [laughter] enough,
I know, I know no one remembers this and
we're getting old, but I can't stress
enough how awesome it was to be able to
listen to music without CDs.
>> Well, to be able to pick the two songs
you wanted to listen to and not have to
buy 15 songs that you didn't,
>> it was incredible. And the same thing
with with Netflix, with video streaming
versus going to a video store.
>> Oh my god.
>> I can't stress
>> how much better it was unequivocally.
>> Yes.
>> In every way. Well, do you remember
before you could watch movies on your
laptop and you're just sitting here
like, I have a laptop. I have a screen.
On this screen, television screen, I can
watch movies. On this screen, you're
telling me that I can't watch.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. What is going on?
>> And you know, something like mapping,
like Google Maps, because it was
competing with nothing, right? Like
there wasn't
>> paper.
>> So, so you you could have on your phone
a real time dot that shows where you are
in the world and you would never get
lost again. Again, I know if you're used
to this stuff, you're like, "Yeah,
whatever. I
>> think about what that was competing
with. There weren't like 10 other
startups doing the same thing. They were
competing with nothing.
>> Sometimes you would just write
directions down on a piece of paper.
>> Yep.
>> Like left at this street, right at this
street d. And then you'd have to like
just do that, right? Good luck.
>> So I think that perhaps the challenge is
we're transitioning. And I think the
analogy that I tried to draw is that,
you know, when you see a country
industrialize and go from kind of a
farming economy to a more industrial
economy, you get this massive increase
in GDP, but you can't like you don't get
that over and over again. Like once the
farmers left the farm, that that's the
game. And one might argue once these
kind of consumer experiences,
directions, travel, like da d the things
we've talked about move online once
the bar to making something in those
spaces better goes way up.
>> Yep.
>> And so if you're a consumer startup
today, you might feel pretty shitty
because it's like you're like, "Hey,
Michael Dalton, you just had to put it
online." You know?
>> Yeah. [laughter] I think the way I would
riff on that is to say we did have it
much easier [laughter]
>> because we were competing with nothing.
Like the internet was a new thing and
there wasn't much on the internet.
>> Well, and putting things online wasn't
like it was like the easiest thing in
the world.
>> You invited invite invented streaming,
dude.
>> Like there wasn't like people
>> no
>> talking to their fam to the chat.
[laughter]
>> Didn't
>> you guys invented that? So, it's much
harder for someone new to come up with a
better version of Twitch.
>> No,
>> because you guys didn't have to compete
with anything at the time.
>> So, they're now startups who are like,
and I I would have been this. I don't
know about you. I [__] hate this B2B
SAS stuff. Like, I don't want to be
doing these like AI is this opportunity
to build great consumer startups? How
should I use it? How would how would we
tell them to think about this? I think
that the most reliable source of great
ideas that we saw over the years is to
look at what the most premium
experiences in the world are that people
with infinite resources have.
>> Yes.
>> And use technology to make them
available to everyone.
>> Yes.
>> And I would argue that is kind of
technology in general. Like we get to
live like kings used to live.
>> Yes.
>> In a bunch of different ways.
>> Yes. And so if you can build a
technology that takes something that is
seen as just super premium and way way
too expensive to be practical
>> Yeah.
>> and bring it to everybody in a cheap
way, I think you're going to have some
success.
>> But I would argue this is tricky because
I would say that, you know, we started
our companies in our 20s when we were
internet users, but we could easily see
the things that weren't on the internet.
>> Yep. And so if you're in your 20s now,
seeing what a hyper premium experience
is, that's a little bit harder. That's
not just that's not just around like you
you might have to search for it a bit
harder.
>> How do you think about that challenge? I
would think about what are the things
that people care about the most that put
the most money into. And so one just to
give some specifics here, I think
healthcare is a really big trend
>> um in the in the modern age. I think
there's still room for improvement to
make healthare experiences way better.
If you've ever, you know, been to a
hospital or interacted with the
healthare system,
>> it's not hard to see that there's room
for improvement.
>> Yes.
>> And I think the thought experiment is
what medical experiences are the most
premium in the world? Like what kind of
health experience does a head of state
have?
>> Yeah.
>> Like how do they interact with the
healthare system? Probably different
than most people. And can you give
whatever that experience that a head of
state would have
>> to everyone? I think that's a really
good startup idea.
>> I would kind of take that one step
further. If you're interested in an
area, let's say healthcare,
>> probably the first thing you should do
is try to figure out what is the most
premium version of it that you're not
going to readily have access to. Yep.
>> You should kind of assume you don't know
what it I mean depending on how you grew
up, but for most people, you should
assume what you're getting isn't
premium. I might argue the trap might be
to start from what you're getting and
try to make it 10% better.
>> Yeah.
>> And the opportunity might be assume
there's an ultra premium version you
don't know about. Go find it. I remember
I had this experience. I need to like
edit some of the details, but I needed a
doctor [laughter]
for for for an injury that I had
[laughter]
>> and it was really really hard to get one
who is good. And then I talked to a rich
investor. I know who you're talking. I
remember this.
>> And they were like, "Oh, there's this
whole other thing over here." And like
for more money, but not crazy amount of
money, you can have this like
experience. And I was like, "Oh my god,
I would have never known." Most people
don't know. But then having that premium
experience, it was like,
>> "Oh, like the normal visit to a health
system is not what this is like." And so
I think you kind of have to dig. And and
you pointed out that that Brian Chesy at
Airbnb, he kind of has a
>> Yeah. He would give a talk at YC and I
think in a nutshell what he would do in
planning meetings like internal Airbnb
planning meetings
>> is to is to take whatever the idea was
or the experience was. Yeah.
>> And then as in the brainstorm say okay
what's the fivestar
version not the fourstar okay what's the
sixstar and so for instance um he would
talk about checking into an Airbnb.
Yeah.
>> You know you show up and the app gives
you access and whatever. Yeah. And so,
you know, maybe the the six-star
experience is a car meets you at the
airport
>> and takes you there
>> and takes you there. Maybe a sevenstar
experience is they hold a parade for
you. [laughter]
>> Maybe for some people,
>> maybe the 11star experience is there's a
parade and they put you on an elephant.
They march you down down the street from
the airport to your Airbnb. And again, I
I don't believe they've built that
feature yet. Um [laughter] but at least
for the sake of the brainstorm, it helps
to stretch your brain to imagine.
>> Yes.
>> To think outside the box of what
increasingly uh premium experiences are.
Well, I want to extend that analogy
because I think that one thing I want to
communicate is this idea that you might
not have to invent these experiences.
They probably exist. It's probably just
that they don't scale very well or
they're very expensive and so they're
not widely available. But like often
times you don't. I mean, Uber didn't
invent black cars,
>> correct?
>> And like I remember when Uber Black
first came out and I was like, as a kid
growing up in New York, people who drove
in black cars were like
>> Yeah.
>> here [laughter] and I was here and and
like I don't even know how like how
would you even do that? [laughter] Like
I the subway I know a taxi I know like I
don't even know you can't knock on the
door like you can't. And when Uber
basically was like, "Oh, you just click
a phone a button on your phone." And one
of them I was like, and it was so funny
because I remember people being like,
"It's more expensive than a taxi." I'm
like, "And it's better." [laughter]
Like, it's also better. So, and you
know, back in the day, you used to hire
a driver and then buy a car and then
they would drive it. Like, it's like
it's way less expensive than [laughter]
that.
>> Yeah. And so what's interesting though
is that those opportunities I think are
floating around today. I actually think
AI can facilitate more of those
experiences, but like I worry that
people might just have to use a
different part of their brain. Like it's
it's it's different. [clears throat]
>> Um some of the folks in the audience
might be like, "Yeah, yeah. That's what
my startup does, guys. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> But let me let me double click on that."
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, I feel like I see a
lot of consumer AI startups that try to
replace things being done with humans
with like chat bots or voice agents.
There are cases where that might be
better. Like for instance, um
>> I don't enjoy calling in to certain
places and being held on hold for an
hour. So, if you could pick up the phone
immediately and fix my problem, okay,
you know, check. But the issue is that a
lot of the experiences aren't actually
that much better than working with a
human. No.
>> And that the pitch that the founders
have is that it's saving money
>> and not that
>> or time or time.
>> And not that it's 100x better. No. And
that's my issue like like my theory of
what will cause really big consumer
companies to come out is the same kind
of like
>> magical feeling that we felt with these
100x better products that that have come
out. And I don't think that's by sort of
approximating a 95% as good version of
uh of what humans do. And again, like
last thing on this, it's like when I
interact with someone over email and I'm
like, "Oh man, this is so horrible. This
is probably someone's open claw I'm
talking to."
>> Yes. Yes. Exactly. [laughter] Yes.
>> I'm like, "Oh, this is this is
horrible." And so if you're building
>> Are you having a premium experience? If
[laughter] if your experience is
effectively someone's like, "Oh man, I
think I'm talking to a claw. This is,
>> you know, unsubscribe, you know, that is
not what we're talking about. That is
not a premium experience."
>> Well, and and what's funny is it's not a
premium experience of the receiver of
the email, but it's also not a premium
experience for the sender of the email.
And that's not talked about enough. If
you're quietly just [__] on everyone
you're trying to communicate with,
[laughter]
that's not good for you. Um, it's like,
"Oh, but but you answered your email so
fast." That's like, "Yeah, but everyone
you're talking to hates you." That's not
[laughter] That's not good. So, I'd like
to play a game. We have a list of
products that have been very popular in
the last 20 years that are consumer
products, and I would love us to kind of
brainstorm a little bit about what 100x
better could be. A weird product for me
was Kayak.
I would say that um Kayak was probably
the first web 2.0 product that I used
that like kind of weirdly just
completely blew me away. Y
>> the product right before was like
airplane sites. Airlines had websites so
you could go one by one and search each
one of them but you couldn't do that.
And the product right before that was
like you called a travel agent and like
they couldn't search all of the like.
So, I just remember the first time I
could be like, "Here's every flight
between these two places." And then I
can drag this thing cuz I want to leave
at like 400 p.m. and I will just see
those flights. I can sort by cheap and
expens like that was mind-blowing to me.
And now, as a more um experienced
traveler,
you know, if you're going to make some
chatbot that automates that process of
finding a flight, like like that's not
like you're not give me the magic. I
think that the magic comes from like
what is an incredible trip if it's a
business trip or what is an incredible
vacation. You know, I see founders who
are like, "Oh, the AI can create my
itinerary." What happens if you had to
be responsible for me having an
incredible trip? Is a premium experience
to hand you an itinerary and say, "No,
[laughter]
>> I've gone on some incredible vacations."
And the premium version of this is um
actually this term I learned from No
Reservations and Anthony Bourdain is
this term called a fixer. And it's
literally a human who is from that place
you're going knows it extremely well and
helps you do everything you want to do.
>> Yep.
>> And doesn't just like do the things that
you say like they know the space really
well. like actually you don't want to go
there, you want to go here or like
actually d and like or you're not
accounting for the fact that you're
going to have jet lag. So like they're
incredible. When you go on a vacation
with a fixer,
>> you're having a 10x better vacation than
other people around you. even when
you're like buying the same stuff. Like
I remember I had a little microcosm of
this experience when I was traveling to
Bolognia and I was talking to some
founders and we went to this restaurant
my wife and I and we had a mediocre meal
and then the next day the founders
wanted to go to the same restaurant and
I was like we hated that place and they
were just like it's like one of the best
restaurants just let us order. And we
went back the second day and just
ordered different stuff and it was one
of the best restaurants and I was like
oh like oh I see. And so to me, if I
were trying to be in the travel space,
it would be like, I mean, when you're
rich, you get incredible vacations.
Like, you get this personal experience.
If you could simulate that for every pe
for everyday people at a reasonable
cost, way above and beyond kayak.
>> Way above and beyond. What about you?
Like, is there is there like a can you
imagine a premium version of a product
that we all know and love?
>> I think one that I think about a lot is
uh is fintech. and I funded a lot of
fintech at YC. I funed Brex and you know
lots of experience. One of the things
that I that I noticed
>> um setting up Standard Capital and
>> uh what have you is I've interacted with
what the high end
>> of a banking experience is. And this is
an example for what you talked about
earlier is I don't think most people
>> understand [laughter]
what it's like yes
>> to have a really good banking
experience. humans will come to your
office and [laughter]
>> so effectively
the super premium banking experience is
you have a person
>> Yeah.
>> who knows you and knows your life story
>> and
is very senior at the place they work
>> and can do a lot of things
>> and whatever problems you have or
whatever help you need with someone you
just like text them
[laughter]
>> and they make stuff happen. Yes. Um,
again, let's use a thought experiment.
We don't need to talk about me, but
imagine if you're like Elon.
>> Yeah.
>> And you're like, "Hey, I need to do this
like banking thing or fintech thing."
Yeah.
>> He would just like text someone and then
they make it happen. They don't say,
"Hey, go fill out this thing or go sit
on this website or go hold on phone for
a long time."
>> Bingo. And so my whole thing about
fintech is I think you could make that
type of experience
>> accessible to way more people. Yes. And
it's the opposite of my credit card
mysteriously got declined or I have this
question and I don't know how to answer
it or I'm gonna call into a phone tree
and talk to a robot. Again, I am
personally not convinced that tons of AI
automation
that remains faceless and unpersonalized
is actually the move. In my mind, what
AI allows is for infinite
personalization.
And like if you know the web 2.0 mobile
allowed for kind of access and for me to
be the kind of primary tool user. It's
weird because it's not just someone
who's an expert. Like I like what you
said they know me too. Like they're an
expert in me.
>> Yeah. Cuz I [laughter] don't want every
time I interact with a bank it to be
like another rando customer support
person. That is not a premium
experience, right?
>> No.
>> I think that there's two things that
come to mind when it comes to banking
that's just like so funny. And I
remember, you know, we had a
relationship with a bank during our
startup and then we continued
um using that bank afterwards as for
private wealth. And I remember there was
a moment where it was kind of like my
parents needed some banking stuff. They
needed accounts. They needed some setup
to it was just they just they were like,
"Well, what's your mom and dad's phone
number?" [laughter]
>> Can you imagine like a a big bank doing
that?
>> No. And literally like I would talk to
my dad and mom every once in a while.
They're like, "Oh yeah, like we have
quarterly calls with your banker about
our thing and D and I'm just like I
didn't even know that was happening,
right?" And so to me it's like I I just
oppose that to the oh when you're
traveling and your card doesn't work
because you didn't tell your bank that
you're like trying it's like [laughter]
you know you're just like
>> and and again what we're trying to say
is you could just do that audience like
like no one is stopping you from doing
this thought experiment.
>> No. and offering those experiences with
technology and build an amazing business
doing so. There's no structural reason
you can't offer that super premium
experience.
>> Well, and and I would argue that AI
makes the business that wouldn't work
before AI work after, right? These
things that we're talking about
fundamentally wouldn't work before. And
if you're kind of still stuck in that
mindset of like, oh, well, there have
been a bunch of different kayaks and
none of them worked. It's like you're
not getting it. Like
>> you're right. On one hand, like making a
10% better kayak is not correct. On the
other hand, what would amazing be?
>> Yep.
>> What would amazing be?
>> And again, shockingly, I think a lot of
people will work on a startup for years
and not have an answer to the question
of what
>> what is an 11star experience? At least
have the thought experiment. Well, and
it's funny because, you know, just to
bring it back to Twitch for a second,
like the 11 star experience, and this
just shows how old it was, was you can
make content online and get paid. Like,
that wasn't a thing. It was it was that
basic.
>> Maybe to riff on one of the things I
think about a lot is
>> we are products of the school system, of
the education system.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think, you know, I went to public
school. Yep.
>> So, I'm a product of the the Texas state
public educ. And again, I'm a fan.
There's not
>> Yeah, it it worked out. It worked out.
>> It worked [laughter] out for me, but
like,
>> you know, there's room for improvement,
I think, is one way to say it. And when
you think about what the design
challenges are of building an education
system,
>> it's you have to serve everybody. And a
lot of the weirder parts of the product
of being educated by a society
>> is the trade-offs they had to make.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. Yes. Yes.
>> Like we were all experiencing everyone.
>> Yeah. But we went through a
one-sizefits-all um education experience
>> and there's clearly room for improvement
and there are people that have a lot of
resources that I think are able to have
very personalized education experiences.
>> Yes.
>> Right. And
>> at every level.
>> At every level. And people watching
this, you could just go do that for
every like we know what good looks like
for education.
>> Yeah. I think everyone will have a super
personalized awesome educational
experience in the future. I agree.
Right. I agree. So to wrap up, I think
that one we're trying to give you a
hint.
Consumer with AI is just starting. Like
so many of these experiences have not
gotten better yet. And so if you're in
the consumer mindset, welcome to the
show. This is a great place to start.
And then I think too,
yeah, you might have to use your
imagination to find some of these ideas,
but also if you just assume that
everything you do, someone's doing it
100x better right now and you go look
for it,
you might find it, you know, it's it's
maybe not being advertised, but it's
also not really hidden.
>> Y,
>> this is an area where some research
could really open your your mind. You
know, if you've got a rich friend or a
rich friend of a friend, like maybe you
just ask them how do how do they get a
tutor? How do they travel? How do they
and and not so that you can just
replicate it, but so you can understand
what great could be and then maybe you
can for how to deliver it to everyone
else.
>> I think the same thing goes even for
entertainment products where maybe I
have a less clear idea about what 100x
better looks like. Yeah. But um when you
think about it, Tik Tok
>> is a very sophisticated algorithm
>> and what you all are competing with if
you're trying to do a consumer product
is a black hole for human attention that
is now many years in not [clears throat]
just Tik Tok but Facebook too,
>> but they have all the content. They
already know kind of what you like and
they can siphon
>> hours a day from a human's attention.
And so you have to be way more
compelling. Yeah.
>> Than that. And this is very different
than building a consumer product 20
years ago when there was no Tik Tok.
There was there was nothing else
competing for these hours per day.
>> No.
>> I mean, you make a really good point.
One, rich people are sucked into social
media just like middle class people,
just like working class people. So like
I I have never seen a rich person I mean
maybe I'm not rich enough. [laughter]
>> There's always another level on Twitter.
>> Basically, what can we learn? What can
we learn um from Trump and from Elon? I
[laughter] think it's that using X is
the most premium experience in the world
and that
>> with infinite wealth you would still
choose to use spend a lot of your waking
hours on that freaking website.
>> Literally
that's the [laughter]
is the highest.
>> Yeah, Trump loves it. So yeah,
>> but if I had to riff on it a little bit,
I would be thinking about just the other
things that bring joy to people's life
when they have wealth versus
I think for a lot of people, Twitter is
their you like the other things around
them are not going great and Twitter or
fill in social media product X. I think
sometimes people just kind of frame
these things as like they're all they're
just all harm no help, but people use
them because they're extracting joy out
of them.
>> Yep.
>> And so if I were to even think about how
to attack this, I would just be like, I
probably can't make more addictive
algorithms, but can I produce more joy?
>> Yeah,
>> I don't know how I do that, but like I
like rich people have a lot more things
that produce joy. Well, again, my riff
on that would be cool inerson
experiences. Like, it'd be hard to fight
fire with fire, but building a more
addictive social media app,
>> but those same people we're talking
about, they also like to do inerson
stuff.
>> They do.
>> And and incredible. Incredible.
>> So, trying to build a more addictive
version of X sounds really hard, but
>> having more in-person experience type
things.
>> Yeah.
>> I want to keep this going. I want to do
two more.
>> Okay. And and and I'm going to give you
the choice and I'll take the other.
Amazon and Door Dash.
>> I'll do Amazon. I think
>> All right. Go ahead. What What is What
is
>> So the problem the problem with Amazon
is it has been SEOed to heck.
>> Oh god. Yeah.
>> And it's just full of crap and the odds
that you'll actually get a good product
are very low.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think the high-end experienced
version of Amazon is you get the best
version of something. It's like wire
cutter type stuff,
>> but there's a you could just ask
someone, you'd be like,
>> "Michael, what's the best X?"
>> And you'd be like, "Oh, it's this."
>> And then you have it.
>> Like Amazon did a really good job of
speed of getting to my house. I don't
know how much more you could improve
that, but man, they have a crap problem.
>> So, I want to I want to I I don't know
the right poker term. I I want to like I
want to raise I want to raise I want to
raise you. I want to raise you. Okay.
>> I would argue that like there are lots
of Amazon purchases that I that that
people do because they're trying to like
maintain something in their life,
maintain their household, maintain their
wardrobe, maintain whatever. I wonder if
that whole maintenance thing could just
be removed.
>> Yep.
>> Right. It's like
not only is is this service going to
pick the things that it knows is good
for me, it's going to take
responsibility for whatever needs to be
maintained, right? Like
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And so it's just kind of like
like, oh, I don't have to, you know, if
I'm clicking on Amazon, many things went
wrong.
>> That's a really good point. [laughter]
>> Almost like uh vacuum cleaner bags. Is
that what you mean? Stuff like that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's just like the things
that should be in my house are there. I
will tell you like, you know, as as a
rich person, I've set up more and more
things like that. And it's really weird
to just like the the best knowledge I
can give you is like anything you reach
for that like there is a thing there.
[laughter] Like it's like, oh, oh, oh.
And and someone else thought about it.
Well, maybe the way I would riff on this
if I were doing office hours with a
founder Yeah. would be
>> if you go to like the Four Seasons or a
high-end hotel.
>> Yeah.
>> What things can you take for granted?
Yes. And offer
>> those things in someone's own home.
>> Like, how do you make living in your
house?
>> Yes.
>> Just like all the goodies you get from a
really high-end hotel. That's probably
the the thought experiment
>> I would that I think that's amazing. I
think that if I were to take Door Dash,
the ultra high-end experience or a ultra
high-end experience is having a personal
chef and having a personal chef who can
customize what you eat, how you eat, the
the health level when it's available to
the point where like you don't
participate in the food system
[laughter]
like like you don't like you don't like
like I'd argue there's like two levels
of food system. There's like the grocery
store and then there's like the
restaurant and then there's just a third
level is just like you don't even
interact with those levels of the food
system [laughter]
and you know hiring a chef is expensive
as hell and then like making sure
they're good. They know who the but like
a 10x better than Door Dash. Like Door
Dash knows what a lot of people in
America like to eat and like Door Dash
has incredible technology inside of the
restaurant.
>> And I think the restaurants are always
trying to figure out how do we
differentiate? How do we do something
like how do we not put ourselves in the
commodity world? And
>> I I do think
this private chef thing where and it's
not just like indulgent. It's actually
kind of like it's healthy even like
>> I think that problem is going to be
solved to generalize this whole thing
for the audience to make sure they get
what we're trying to say. What we're
trying to say
>> is really awesome consumer experiences
for the masses
>> start high-end.
>> Yes.
>> Like air travel.
>> Used to be very highend and now it's
awesome that so many people in the world
can afford to fly on a plane.
>> Yes.
>> Same with cars. Owning a car was a
ridiculous luxury experience.
Ridiculous. And now you know a lot of
people own cars. That's a real And so
what we're trying to argue is to be
inspired
>> by the ideas of this stuff. But of
course the point is to make it
accessible to everyone. Everyone should
have amazing healthare.
>> Yes. Yes. [laughter]
And that's so important because I think
that like maybe today in our political
climate it's kind of like
>> it's this glass half full or like you
know the pie is only so big. So we can't
give those amazing experiences to
everyone, right? And it's like, "No, no,
no, no, no. [laughter] We we can. We
can." And and like we will. And and
history is just a story of us doing that
over and over [laughter] and over again.
>> Like everyone should have the same
quality healthcare that a head of state
has.
>> Yes. Yes. And I think that's going to
happen. That's doable.
>> When everyone today has a higher quality
of healthcare than a president did 100
years ago, [laughter]
>> 100%.
>> And and so along that path, people saw
what great was and said, "Let me give it
to everyone." And let's not belittleable
belittle the people who maybe are living
a lifestyle that you can't afford. Let's
figure out how to give that lifestyle to
everyone. And and that's that's very
possible. All right. Cool. Good chat.
>> All right. Thanks, Michael.